hey leute was klappt willkommen bayern
mein video ich habe es eigentlich kurz
mal vor
einfach so drauflos zu lauern wird nicht
lange dauern 23 minuten vielleicht oder
so wäre cool wenn ihr euch das video
komplett anschaut
auf jeden fall habe ich so entschieden
dass ich so meine upload tage keine
ahnung ich hab jetzt mittwoch am samstag
ist ja ok aber ich mir passt es halt
anders besser ich habe generell zurzeit
youtube und so das bag bei mir ein
bisschen rum ich wollte jetzt einfach
mal so alles bisher neu machen und
deswegen auch ein bisschen was online
upload tagen ändern also jetzt kommen
halt immer vermisst der sonntag an dem
tag keine mir wahrscheinlich das video
seht also heute sonntag ich habe jetzt
vor immer montags und mittwochs meine
videos online zu stellen aber wochenende
halt nicht weil keine ahnung wochenende
kann ich schön was drehen
aber halt nichts online stellen so
können finde ich heute ganz gut einfach
einer woche das zu machen also montags
um 15 uhr mittwochs um 15 uhr kommen
immer neue videos deswegen schreibt euch
das in euren keine ahnung ist es mir
egal hauptsache er denkt an
und ja also auf jeden fall ab montag 15
uhr mittwochs 15 uhr morgen kommt da
schon das nächste video dann direkt mit
100 will ich auch auf jeden fall morgen
ab und außerdem habe ich jetzt noch
ich habe früher sehr oft gestreamt ich
hab's gar nicht mehr gemacht weil keine
ahnung ich weiß ich nicht warum
und ich habe bei einem junior account
gelingt findet ihr in der video
beschreibung und da habe ich einfach
weiter zu machen also ich hab da auch
sogar von 5.000 aber ich weiß nicht
warum ich da nicht mehr weiter gemacht
hat weil es macht eigentlich spaß
deswegen freue ich mich auf jeden fall
wenn ihr wollt und heute abend ist dann
logischerweise auch schon ein erstes
team den habe ich halt was heißt so
geschmeidig wie jeden sonntag abend für
eine halbe stunde bis dreiviertelstunde
stream so heiß wird kippe ich mal
und ja würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr
da einfach mal drauf klickt und da einen
folgen hinterlasst sag mal so ich weiß
es nicht
auf jeden fall so erstmal das grobe also
es gibt praktisch drei termine die woche
an dem ich ertragen könnte oder müsste
ein spaß
auf jeden fall so viel dazu und weißt du
noch sagen wollte irgendwann will ich
noch sagen glaube ich keine ahnung ich
hab es dann geht diesmal nicht wissen ja
besser ins netz stellen kann ist auch in
der video beschreibung ins programm
natürlich auch als wickrath michael und
ja deswegen morgen checkt das video ab
und wir sehen uns dann heute abend beim
livestream
ich freue mich auf euch 3